if you think of shooting a movie and
making a movie as the same thing you've
overlooked one of the most important
elements of filmmaking the editing
editors infuse a film with rhythm
they build suspense and they create
moments that otherwise would not have
existed and as an actor they can make
things like your performance a whole lot
better trust me
and here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing black
clansmen Barry Alexander Brown Bohemian
Rhapsody John Hoffman the favorite your
ghost mob Rob Sarita's Greenbaum Patrick
Jay Don Vito fight Hank :
and the Oscar goes to Bohemian Rhapsody
Jonathon nomination for Jonathan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he just asked me if I would like this
nice said sure my mom would like it
who's here over there she's 85 years old
wow you get up here in the completely
blank this film I always like to say is
the entire cast and crew likes to always
say was a labor of love and I think
Freddie Mercury in a way kind of brought
us all together from wherever he is and
just like he did his audience and I just
am so thankful for everyone bonding
together and supporting each other and
trusting me and I want to I mean there's
too many people to thank of course I
look around me right right looking at me
better thank me got the band over here
thank you so much Brian May and Roger
Taylor and um and I have to mention of
course
Graham King and Dennis Sullivan to the
hardest working and committed producers
I've ever worked with my life and lastly
this goes to my parents on their
fireplace mantel because there they
encouraged me to do whatever I wanted to
do when I was a kid where there was
writing music which was a mystery to
them or making films in their garage and
Normanton away in San Jose California so
so as Freddy's the father would say good
thoughts good words good deeds thank you
[Applause]